this podcast is brought to you by on it
go to audit.com and look at the great
selection of supplements if you find
something you like pressing code Joey
and get 10 off delivered right to your
house what's happening you bad
[__] the joint is brought to
you by rocket money how much are you
paying for all your subscriptions I bet
you don't even have a clue you could be
wasting hundreds of dollars each month
on subscriptions you don't even know
about that's why I love rocket money
formerly known as true bill this app
shows you all your subscriptions in one
place and cancels whatever ones you
don't want rocket money can find you
ones you didn't even know you were
paying for you may even find out you've
been double charged how's that so to
cancel a subscription just press cancel
and Rocket money takes care of the rest
it's that easy get rid of useless
subscriptions with rocket money now go
to Rocket money dot com slash Joey it
could save you hundreds per year again
that's rocketmoney.com Joey cancel your
unnecessary subscriptions right now at
rocketmoney.com Joey let's get this
party started it's Monday morning
[__]
check one two welcome to Uncle Joey's
joint
[Music]
foreign
what's happening you bad [__]
Uncle Joey here and a beautiful cold
Monday [__] morning the 16th of
January uh you know I like what like
people been teasing me since I moved to
Jersey like there's always one [__]
knucklehead like hey man how's Jersey
are you are you done with the cold
weather yet [__] we've been rocking in
the 60s [__] December I mean it's
been a it's been a very weird uh winter
I'm not gonna call you up and bust your
balls like hey it's raining in
California it's sunny here in 40 today
who gives a [__] because I know you got
to pay the piper
listen we're going to get 100 inches of
snow it's either scattered but during
three months or it could all hit you in
February you follow me I mean that that
just I know in the back of my head
through experience the winters are a
[__] the east coast and yeah my
last two Winters here have been yeah a
little on the mild side we haven't lost
any [__] nobody loses a day from
transportation and [__] like that but
those days are [__] coming and I I
understand everybody talking about
global warming and [__] it has [__]
changed I mean it's listen it's Wild
Card Weekend okay in the NFL whenever I
think a wild card I think a [__] cold
weather it takes me back
to maybe 1994.
I had a gig in one of those [__]
freezer towns when I say it's just a
freezer when you get there you'll see
the Wyoming or Montana I think it was
Wyoming because it's closer to Boulder
it was like a two three hour drive and
I'll never forget this as long as I look
this is what I whenever I hear wild card
that's what I [__] think about
because it was one of those San
Francisco 49er days like in Dallas or
some [__] and I'll never forget like
there was no Coke in Wyoming I just went
back to my hotel room and [__] looked
out a window and listened to country
music whatever the [__] they do and I
just couldn't fall asleep and the next
morning I woke up you know late like I
missed a little hot
cake breakfast that they had the thing
and I asked the guy amen
do you mind uh what do I eat breakfast
around he's like oh there's a breakfast
spot about two blocks away it's like a
five minute walk seven minute walk I go
all right no he didn't even save like a
five minute walk he says like a seven
minute drive
know and I'm like
I could do that in my sleep you know I'm
30 years old let's do this I bundled up
and as I was hitting the door he goes
yeah he goes you have a car and I go no
I'm gonna walk he goes you're not gonna
make it look at this [__] bum [__]
doesn't know I came from blizzard City
NYC you know dog three [__] minutes
three minutes
I was getting hit with gusts the [__]
air I never forget going inside like
just gonna [__] it I'll live with hunger
pains I'll live on chips I'll never
forget going back and feel it how long
it took my little pants to warm up
like my pants and just surrounded my
[__] legs and they were freezing I'd
no long underwear I had layers you know
you put [__] layers on but it was
brutal
and it's it's it's now I look around
January 15th we've had what 10 60 degree
days so far in January maybe five and
then I've been like 40 and 50 but this
week the wind chill [__] went down
the winch the wind's blowing and once
that [__] wind's blowing
it's Snappy Nunu time and I gotta be
honest with you guys about something
some of you are going to call me a [__]
or whatever
I don't know if I was to wait too long I
don't know what it was
Uncle Joey in cold weather it ain't
clicking no more like it used to I love
[__] cold weather it never bothered
me you know
and you hear people tell you oh I go to
Florida in the winter you know my bones
I'm gonna tell you something my bones
don't hurt nothing freezes up on me
I tell you the worst part of living in
the east coast and this is for me
getting in your car in the morning
that's it that's it I love going out
there starting that [__] up I I
put the seats on [__] fire I put the
car on Satan and I just come in the
house and I won't go out there till that
mother so I see the windows melting I
get in that car in the first five
minutes I'm like [__] I gotta take my
jacket off it's burning in here I can't
deal with it like when I go somewhere
if I know I gotta go somewhere and I'm
in that place for a while I [__] run
outside I start the corn I go back in I
don't give a [__] anymore you want to
take my Subaru [__] take it it's
going to be warm when you take it you
know what I'm saying but I'm done I
can't I don't know I told Jimmy a couple
weeks ago like we used to go to wreck
games
[__] October once the sun goes down
this [__] at night in October wants to
you go to these softball games and all
this activity [__] out here and it's
great it's beautiful till the [__]
son gets behind those trees and you're
like holy [__] it's [__] I can't do
it no more guys
I lived in Colorado for 12 years and I
know a lot of you people like well if
you lived in Colorado here's the thing
where I lived in Boulder Aston and
Snowmass
if I was there for 12 years 13 years
I probably had 10 days where I was like
this is not good
maybe I
maybe 10 days maybe maybe I don't even
think it was 10 days just you know
Colorado is not that cold on paper
you see all the snow and [__] it scares
you I didn't though I still remember
going to a Monday night football game in
Colorado Kansas City against Denver when
Joe Montana played the [__] Kansas
City when he got traded that it was you
know I don't know what it was supposed
to be out people were like dress warm I
still remember taking off my jacket
like the LA you know and I had layers on
two T-shirts a sweatshirt maybe a hooded
sweatshirt whatever the [__] but I had
like one of those down jackets whatever
I was dying the heat I was like this is
[__] hot on Monday Night Football I
was warm I still remember hitchhiking
and Aspen with a [__] t-shirt on and
a pillowcase with my lunch in there and
people pull up next to me and go are you
not cold and I'm like no I still
remember being [__] freezing and me
walking around with a flannel t-shirt
and that was it as a matter of fact I
had a cop talk to me once in Aspen
because I went out with my flannel
underwear on you know those long johns
the old school long johns in North
Bergen we always wore them out [__] it
just put a pair of long johns on as long
as you have underwear underneath and
your [__] balls aren't swinging from
side to side insulting people nobody's
gonna say nothing to you so I would put
[__] long johns on with a Long John
t-shirt and that'll be walking that
people would be looking at me with work
boots on with long john suit with work
boots people what the [__] are you
thinking aren't you [__] cold no
that's why they're called [__]
goddamn warm suits whatever I don't even
know what that gold but man I don't know
what it's been the last couple of times
I come back east
to do comedy on the road I'm like Jesus
because you know I don't have a winter
jacket
who has a winter jacket living in
California so I moved here without a I
got one winter jacket it's a [__]
jacket I took from the dog that say
[__] uh one of those movies I did
with the [__] dogs Dad we did the one
in Colorado and it was freezing and they
were like you need a winter jacket I'm
like I ain't got one I live in [__]
California why would I have a [__]
winter jacket and they gave me a winter
jacket I still got it upstairs I [__]
hate it it's brown but who you know
where I lived we needed to [__]
winter jacket now my wife for Christmas
finally got me a [__] tremendous
winter jacket I mean I told her because
I sought advertised somewhere that it's
warmest jacket out I'm like listen I
don't know what your budget is for
Christmas but just give me one [__]
thing and just give me that [__]
jacket and she gave it to me
dog this times I put I don't even know
what type of jacket it is it's one of
those Colorado ski jackets I saw it
advertised that they put a lining of it
looks like aluminum foil
my jacket looks like [__] aluminum
foil if I show you the inside you're
like what the [__] guys this times I put
that [__] on in the car
and I gotta take it I sweat my boy if
you zip this [__] up to the top and you
drive around you're like God damn it I
gotta it's like a norm but you guys know
what norvathak is it's like a [__]
thing you put on your legs or your arms
and it opens up uh nor of attack that's
what it's called they have my
cryotherapy places whatever who gives a
[__] uh
so it happens when you smoke Reef from a
Monday morning [__] it's a
beautiful [__] day to be alive
guys I don't know if you've noticed this
it is the 16th of the month
again
it is the 16th of the [__] month
where the [__] did the last two weeks
ago we were just popping champagne
bottles talking about how bad Dick Clark
show was this year and it's already the
16th of the [__] month I'm just
telling you guys a little piece of
[__] advice you're young whatever
you know I remember being 24 and going I
need to get my [__] together
nah [__] it I'm 24. I got till I'm 30.
you know like yeah that was the back of
my mind like I was always like
I'm 24 so what I don't have a [__]
car I got till I'm 30. so what you know
that's when you think you're gonna get
serious and I'm gonna tell you something
30 sneaks up
on you freaking the [__]
especially when you're having fun when
you're having hungovers and you read
this and you're waking up with foam
coming out of your mouth and [__] like
that you're having a good time but it
goes by
[__] fast and every once in a while
you like that [__] groundhog that
pops his head up I swear to God that's
how my life felt that's how my life felt
every once in a while you pop your head
up and you're like hmm I'm 29. [__] it I
got three more years to snort coke this
so I'm I'll grow it and then one day you
wake up when you're 36
and you're like [__]
I still live in an apartment
you know I'm driving a car that's helped
by duct tape
I have no [__] wardrobe you know and
I'm talking about mate guys I'm not
talking about anybody else I'm talking
about me at 37 years old when I met
Tyree I had a [__] bag
and that was my possessions I had a bag
filled with three pair of jeans maybe
four pair of socks underwear that was
what I was looking at when I was 37.
I met Terry I was her apartment one day
and I'm like I'm 37. and I have [__]
nothing
this ain't no [__] joke that's how
fast time moved like I was 26 out of
prison dancing the halfway house getting
into comedy you know and you're like
yeah I'm gonna get my life together I'm
gonna get my life together I'm gonna get
my life together and dog one day I was
32. and I was trying to get serious
about my life
and next thing you know I was 37 and a
half years old
and I had nothing
I was a regular at the [__] store
I had balls of steel and a lot of heart
but
three dollars in my pocket
no finances no car
no nothing and it was time at 37 I was
basically 20 [__] one
like if you really think of how immature
I was I had nothing at 37 nothing guys
and I had popped my head up and I'm like
holy [__]
whoever the [__] did the time go and you
start looking at your friends and they
already have kids
and creepy
it's a lot worse than feeling creepy you
just feel like [__] you know we're
talking about this couple weeks ago
with the sagora thing when he was uh you
know bitching that people [__] at him
guys that is such a rough patch like my
20s and 30s
needed I needed therapy to recover from
those [__]
and then I got right into comedy which
is a no world you know everybody's
telling you no you can't do this we
can't represent you you didn't book this
you didn't book that you're not good
enough to do this and you gotta fight
yourself through all that [__] you know
for me it was wild so before I get into
this even further
just
be uh
uh be cautious to your time
that's the biggest advice somebody gave
me one time I didn't take
I didn't even think of the advice that
[__] gave me until I was like
40.
I was like I remember what Jim handy
told me one day to be cautious with your
time
you know you don't know how much you
have of it you don't know you might as
well jump on it and then there's the two
trainer thoughts guys
there's the I'll party till I'm 30 and
I'm [__] work till I'm 65. you know
listen
I'm going to tell you something guys and
it's overwhelming it's overrated there's
no such thing as Retirement
you know there's no such thing as
Retirement you know I talked to my uncle
a lot I'm really typing my uncle and I
have become great friends over the years
and even tied up since I left uh
California he's gained my respect and
I've gained his respect and we talk
about a lot of things he's 85. this
[__]
still stays up two nights a week working
it takes them all week to recover like
he recovers all [__] week he has to
walk and lift weights and you know eat
and sleep but there's two nights a week
he goes into work at nine o'clock he
doesn't get home till five in the
morning he's 85 [__] years old
and I talked to him I ask him questions
how do you feel what's your health like
this listen when I talk to him I feel
pretty [__] good I got a chance to
last till 85. no I don't want to be 85
I'm going to be all [__] up with
[__] spots on my face and you know
I'm puking and I'm wearing a bag nobody
wants to be 85 and stuff I mean nobody
wants to die either you don't want to
[__] just go I don't want to be that
age I just want to die but I look at my
uncle and I'm like you know what there's
some hope my aunt's 78
I got another Uncle who's 88 in Cuba his
older brother is still alive so I go to
them for advice like I'm not advice but
you know what do you do
to last a [__] 88 you know
you know and Carmine balzada once told
me when you stop using it you lose it
you know I'm not the type that's gonna
get up in the morning
and go fishing
I'm not the type that's gonna get up in
the morning I've thought of things to do
as I get older I mean I like podcasting
I got it down in one day a week I enjoy
I enjoy talking about sports and I enjoy
talking about gambling
that's why I work with DraftKings that's
the reason why it's uh
it's just easy for me I love I'm not a
gambling degenerate I'm not [__]
going to every track I'm not scoping out
information I do a [__] uh whatever
yesterday it was three games I think I
bet two of them
and uh I move on with my [__] life it
doesn't dictate me but I [__] enjoy
it you know and that's what I enjoy now
but back to what we were talking about
you have the two trains of thoughts you
could bust your ass
and take your life a little easier like
when you're 40 which I I never had the
opportunity to do that life like to have
a house or anything or you could
listen it's your [__] Journey
it's your journey so you pick it if
you're not if you're okay by looking at
other people
and not getting feeling insecure like I
always felt insecure I'm 32 I don't have
this I'm 35 I don't have this I'm 40. I
don't have this right now in the state
that we're at in this country it's going
to be very hard
for somebody young to buy a house it's
[__] a horrible horrible and guess
what they don't want you to have a house
they don't want you to have a house they
want you to rent the rest of your
[__] life so don't feel bad about
that you know I was [__] I didn't
have my first call
I don't know how [__] old I was I had
friends that had [__] z28s when they
were 16 and a half they couldn't even
have a car till they were 17. I'm on a
[__] number one bus we're going up to
Kennedy Boulevard busting my ass waiting
for the bus in the winter time that
that's shitty [__] life but I did it
and I pay you know I wanted to snort
coke and jump up and down you know you
can't have your [__] cake and eat it
too you know that's the way life is so
for me I didn't know what was going to
happen I just wanted to [__] die at
some points in my life I was like why am
I still alive I snuck coke with two
hands I eat potato chips you know I
don't take care of myself but I don't
know somebody had a bigger [__] plan
but for me it was I lucked out my I
somebody told me these words one time
and I took them to heart because it fit
me and who I was and it's like it's not
a Sprint it's a [__] Marathon
and you do it to how it works for you
and how accordingly it works for you
don't worry about the people around you
are doing that will put you in a [__]
grave that will make you go to therapy
if you start comparing yourself to other
people and listen I didn't learn that
until I started going to Jujitsu that if
I look at a 20 year old and go why am I
doing that Joey he's you got it you got
him by 40 [__] years
you know you could you could do
everything you want in the world you're
not going to be able to do that but
there's things you're going to be able
to do
work on those
who's better than your Uncle Joey
[__] nobody [__]
talk to you about [__] Lisa yet
you know Mike and I were talking some
[__] about lisaat before how
guys
if today if the church was still around
let's get back to what Mike and I were
covering we were talking about
like comparisons and [__] like that with
your life I was just telling Mike
how after leaded the last Zoom not the
last Zoom the last time Lee was in
studio and we did a podcast I don't know
maybe two or three months ago
I realized that Lee and I
careers podcasters
were really officially over
like I when I when we ended the church
we ended at amicably and it was just a
great run eight years time to move the
[__] on you know
we can lead that life anymore whatever
it was just rough on us the Edibles the
10 000 milligrams of [__] night my my
piss was coming out purple with smoke on
it you know my smoke would come out of
my dick then piss would come out then a
little smoke would come out of your dick
when that happens
you got a [__] problem so uh
I was telling Mike that [__]
you know
when Lee was here last last podcast we
did together
that was when I left here and I was a
little sad that day after the podcast
was up I didn't say nothing to anybody I
never thought of doing the church again
like I never because I knew
there was no way there was no way we
could keep up with the smoking and the
Edibles there's no way that was just a
window in time you know what I'm saying
but
I realized that data we were done as
podcast Partners we're still great
friends I love them with all my heart
but as far as partners or whatever that
was done with the podcast type [__] you
know
and
I was telling Mike before that Lee and I
were talking a few weeks ago and he was
telling me you know we're talking about
the church
and if we did the church again like
I don't have the time
it's so funny how your life changes
when we did the church it was a five
hour minimum Adventure all the time
you know we would do the church at we
would meet at seven and we would leave
there at 12 30 one in the morning
sometimes we'd leave at 6 30 we'd get
new Edibles or new [__] weed strain
or something and we'd meet there an hour
before we would smoke
[__] an eighth before the podcast
would even start man an eighth
between bong heads and joints and bloods
and then eating Edibles and then who
would stop by while we're doing the
podcast I don't have the [__] time
anymore like I was telling Michael I
feel so suddenly I told I was telling
Mike I told Lee that I feel bad because
I don't do anything with my we do a
podcast and that said Mike don't have
the [__] time to jump up and down and
neither do I we got kids we got you know
in La yeah I still had mercy those five
years but I had more of a window she was
younger my wife wasn't working I had
more time that ships out my wife went
back to [__] work she's like if
you're not gonna travel I'm going back
to work and I didn't blame her but it's
so funny how your life changes
speaking of Life Changes I got to talk
to you about my sponsors real quick and
now for a word my [__] sponsors
so they're sponsored by better help
listen when life gets you feeling
overwhelmed working with a therapist
makes you more prepared to take on
anything life throws at you listen
life is getting overwhelming you know
for the last couple of years it's been
overwhelming and sometimes I need to
talk to somebody and better help is the
therapy option that is convenient
flexible affordable and entirely online
listen guys uh you can fill out a brief
question there get matched with a
licensed therapist and switch therapists
anytime for no additional charge it's
very easy they helped me out when I was
in the in a my mind could not even
function I did not know what was going
on after my move and I worked with Dana
she gave me different exercises and
different coping skills and listen if
you want to talk to somebody if you want
to see them it's all up to you better
help is here to help you so if you want
to live a more empowered life therapy
can get you there visit betterhelp.com
Diaz to get 10 off your first month
again that's betterhelp.com
Diaz the joint is also brought to you by
DraftKings listen UFC 283 is almost here
[__] witness the historic match with
Figueroa figarito facing Moreno for the
fourth time this Saturday plus you got
other tremendous fights on that card
check out DraftKings Sportsbook the
official sports betting part of the UFC
new customers can bet five dollars and
203 bets instantly
picks I got for you for this weekend I
tell you what I have nothing until
weigh-ins but there's a lot of fights
you keep your eyes on and for more
excitement check out the playoff action
all weekend for the NFL download the
DraftKings Sportsbook app now and use
promo code Joey j-o-e-y new customers
can bet five dollars on UFC 283 and get
200 and free bets instantly that's code
Joey only at DraftKings Sportsbook the
official sports betting partner of the
UFC minimum age and eligibility
restrictions apply see show notes for
details now back to the show all right
anyway we're back it's so funny in two
years
how the window of my life changed like I
don't have [__] those six hours to do
I love to sit around with somebody get a
[__] I went to look at some offices as
we not good
I went to Thursday I went down to
uh
uh Neptune
Neptune which just saying that word
scares me I came from Neptune New Jersey
when I was a kid for bitty basketball it
was a terrible experience I never
thought I'd be back to Neptune and now I
live what 20 minutes 30 minutes from
[__] Neptune so I went down the
Neptune to look at the [__] uh at an
office there day and not not too [__]
chabby we're gonna keep I I know a lot
of realtors in this area so like last
night I was talking to one guy and I go
if you see anything you know let me know
a garage
I will put heaters in there I like that
[__] on fire we'll have a good
time in there
but back to what we're talking about
it's uh
just time things change man things
change they're not gonna say things I
I've had that experience since I moved
back here you know I moved back after 40
years to to let me know
what my life was really like where I
stood in my life with my friends my life
my my whole [__] thing so I don't
mind any of this [__] at all things
change guys they're not going to be the
same forever as a matter of fact Lee
called me the other night
I was uh watching The Honeymooners of my
daughter Saturday night just we're just
we'd watch honeymoons every [__]
Saturday
and Lee called me up
you know guys my phone used to ring
all [__] day
now it rings during business hours
nobody calls at night thank God
every once in a while
the phone rings my brother George Lee
maybe a California somebody from
California wants to check in
and it's so [__] weird
the other night my phone rang at
midnight
I was like
who the [__] calls me at midnight thank
God I was even downstairs because I
usually put the phone on the charger and
we go upstairs to the living room we
watch TV up there I just happened to be
downstairs
and I go at least calling me at midnight
there's got to be a [__] problem you
know like
I pick up the phone what's up buddy it's
like you can't probably believe what
happened so I'm like okay he's not in a
car accident or something you know what
I'm saying like you're answering the
phone like help help are you the man are
you the man I'm I'm stuck I'm [__]
four hours from
but I thought I was gonna answer the
phone for him to tell me something weird
I got into a car accident or something
no
he goes she's not going to believe what
happened you know Lee and I
Lee was a nice naive kid when they met
me he's still very nice and naive but
Lee picked up a [__] Hustler skill
I'm very proud of him for he picked up a
little hustler skill he listened to all
those years
and it brings a [__] it brings me
great joy when somebody listens
not only do they listen they execute
what they listen to
and they find the happiness that you
found in doing those same things
guys it's a whole new year and and you
know what I don't know what happened
with you last year but maybe you're not
as aggressive as you should be
you know I'm not being the aggressor
anymore like I was I'm a very aggressive
[__] guys
when I want something if I want it bad
enough I will [__] get it no ma
regardless I will work towards that
[__] goal listen what is that Mike
how much is that microphone that
microphone is eight thousand dollars we
don't have eight thousand dollars but
guess what we'll work towards that
[__] goal we would do weddings I
don't give a [__] we'll do weddings
we'll do the open mic but our goal is
eight thousand dollars for that thing
you know
we've whitened it up a little bit over
the years with and I've done the same
with the word Golds and all these things
listen man
want
is everything you know I don't want to
be a [__] loser anymore I don't want
to [__] struggle for [__] anymore I
don't want to argue with my wife about
money anymore and that's the number one
[__] destroyer of a relationship I
don't want so what do you do what's the
opposite of this [__] you got to stick
up to the point you the phone is not
ever gonna [__] ring you have to tell
yourself
phone is not ever gonna ring nobody
wants to work with me I mean that's what
because that's what will set your ass on
fire sometimes
for me it was always comedians comedians
used to piss me the [__] off in the way
that and then it was regular people in
life from expectations of what they
should have or what they should be
getting listen you know what you ever
see the movie you ever seen a video
Remember the Time by Michael Jackson
[__] one of my favorite videos of all
time they're sitting there they got
[__] servants and slaves and people
[__] cutting cherries for you and
rubbing your feet and I guess what
I want that
we all want that yeah right somebody
[__] throwing grapes in your mouth
and [__] we want that you know we all
want that if you [__] if you look at
me and go joy I don't want that I want
to live in a shack you're [__] a liar
okay we all want those things
but they're not you know we don't have
them we don't you've ever seen the
[__] uh a picture of what's that City
that floats
Emirates or Saudi Arabia the other one
where everybody goes not Saudi Arabia
there where they have the fights and
[__] like that
that's [__] a beautiful place yeah
Dubai and all that it's [__]
beautiful the [__] you need your car
needs to be worth a half million to
drive there
like I don't know I'm making this up but
look at the [__] cars you see that
there's no [__] Subaru wagons in
[__] Dubai okay I mean we all want
that lifestyle we all want to party walk
on the [__] Jet Set right people you
know he walked in to the ball like he
was walking on through the yacht we all
want to be big shots whatever Carly
Simon You're So Vain I love that song
but it's like that's that's you could
sit there and wait for somebody to give
it to you which what are the chances
you could wait and win the [__]
Powerball which what are the [__]
chances
or you could be the aggressor
what's the aggressor one of the things
that [__] rattled my life
and this is one of my biggest arguments
with this book was that they wanted to
change Mr Blue's name
Mr Blue was my God
when I think back to my life Mr Blue was
my God
I my God is Jesus you know with all the
holy spirit all those [__] characters
but then you have like another God okay
and Mr Blue was my God because he
settled my life's question
he told me one day he goes you could do
whatever the [__] you want if you put
your mind to something
you could do it you wanted those two
kilos didn't you
and you put your mind through it you put
the guy in the trunk and you got a
machine gun you figure it out you could
put your mind to this [__] you know if
you had something he told me if I had
something you wanted I might as well
give it to you because if you really
wanted it you're gonna take it from me
those are [__] scariest and the most
powerful words anybody ever said to me
gotta take it guys nobody's just gonna
put it there and you're just gonna zip
along and [__] whoo look at me they
jeffed back left his guitar no it don't
work that buck away you know and
you know when the opportunity came up to
for me becoming a comic it seemed
it seemed like you know you ever look at
something that's like 16 hours away and
you're like I don't know if I'm gonna
get that 30 miles an hour because that's
the most this car does it's a [__]
Prius
that's how I looked at being comedy I
looked at doing comedy so I looked at it
again I go you know what I'm not going
to get all the way out there but I'll
get somewhere in the middle
I'm pretty good I'm good enough that I
could get somewhere in the [__]
middle there
but when I got that way
I saw what was there and I figured out a
way on how to [__] attack it for me
anything you want in your life is
attainable to you it may be little
things or maybe something big I hope you
go for little things before you go for
the big things so you don't get yourself
all [__] up
but you get it you set a plan up and you
[__] attack it and you do that the
same way for everything
you know I talk about the movies I got
do you think I got The Longest Yard
because I'm a good looking dude
I think I got the longest shot because
that was the funniest dude no I got the
longest shot because I [__] wanted it
I got Spider-Man 2 because I [__]
wanted it I got the things I got I
zeroed in on I zeroed in on and attacked
them I knew I could fill that [__]
Gap you didn't see me go for Romeo and
Juliet did you and be pissed off about
not getting the father [__] Romeo do
I look up [__] Romeo to you
[__] no but I look at even what
I did with that I zeroed in I picked up
the phone
for you people who love to send emails
and read Yelp go [__] yourself that's
not going to do anything the phone call
with the email will help
but you know we just got to pick up our
game a little [__] more you want that
what's the [__] plan to get that this
is the plan step step by step it's like
the 10 Crack Commandments right remember
it's step by step you know when I I
still remember living in Seattle and
Josh Wolf and
somebody else I've cracked gas
saying to me how the [__] are you
getting all this work every week
and I'm like Monday morning regardless
how much coke I snorted how much ass I
ate the night before what time I went to
and this is way before I didn't have a
[__] computer in 1990 [__] 5 96 98
I would get up walk the Kinkos
I would make a [__] calendar up with
[__] lines with myself at Kinkos boom
boom every [__] Monday ten to nine I
[__] make a calendar I put a month of
January I'd start the 16th right like
tomorrow today is the 16th and I would
Monday I'm at the underground Tuesday
I'm at this place Wednesday I'm at this
Thursday I'm off Friday I'm off Saturday
I mean and I would fax it to Donna
Richards in Portland Oregon I would fax
it to the Cuban dude who booked their
old improv and forget what his name was
I would fax it to the lady in Seattle
that booked one-nighters I would fax
them to [__] Yoder in Michigan I
didn't give a [__] Jack just to let him
know what that was working even though I
was far away from him I would [__]
email that [__] the club in
Florida where I met Jimmy Florentine
Uncle Funny's they would get a [__]
fax to that what were my chances of
getting the [__] Uncle Funny's in
Florida but I was put putting the word
out it's indirect marketing I'm putting
the word I'm letting you [__] know
I'm working [__] up is and eventually
one day you'll [__] call me and
that's what happened I ended up working
for Uncle funnies I mentioned me [__]
Florentine 400 for the week to feature
it was 200 just for the [__] plane
ticket
this is what you need to do anyway don't
get me riled up more than when I'm
already riled up guys like this so I was
talking to Lydia and I Lee called me up
and he said he was gonna go see Jesus
Trail
on
Saturday night it must have been like
Thursday
and he called he called me we're talking
I go say hello to Jesus Jesus a [__]
great kid and he's on his definitely
[__] on his way out
so I called Lee and he's telling me he's
gonna go see he bought tickets he's
gonna go see Jesus Trail I go why don't
you do this why don't you hit him up
with an email he was a good idea or
maybe he said it to me he goes good idea
I go just tell them that you're going to
be there you want to come to see him
does he need anything you know sure
enough Jesus Trail the real comic that
he is turns around and off is Leah guess
it you know he knows Lee you know that
made Lee's [__] worlds
so Lee had a guest set for The Late Show
on Saturday
I guess Lee went to dinner they were out
of [__] horse meat or whatever the
[__] restaurant he went to you know
they were out of [__] piccolilly and
chow chow and he uh he [__] went to
the club early and the guy goes I'm
happy you came the feature act canceled
you're gonna feature for me today so he
got to do the first show he got to do
the second show he got paid and he
picked up a weekend in Worcester
somewhere and one-nighter
Doug I could feel the excitement of his
voice and I was so excited for him
because he didn't sit there and wait for
[__] somebody to call him that's how
you get work guys
that's how you do it you don't show up
on Saturday hey what are you doing here
I didn't know they did comedy here no he
bought tickets
he bought tickets because you know Lee's
a class [__] act he bought tickets he
[__] and reached out to the guy on
text or whatever Instagram or Twitter
and Jesus said yeah [__]
come by
he went through all the proper things he
was going there on a date he didn't
expect anything
and that's what happens but again
nothing happens on the couch
and again nothing happens like I said he
bought tickets versus support
and then he just went through the
[__] channels
and baboon the rest is [__] history I
can't be mad at someone like that you
know when I was [__] going out every
weekend I'd have people that were
aggressive towards me
and I appreciated some of them some of
them
it's not
it's that they were aggressive and they
came at me the wrong way
you know hey man I'm coming down here
with 10 guys how much time can I do
[Music]
you know what are you talking about what
the [__] are you talking about I'm
already bringing a feature act I don't
know what the club is gonna have hit me
up and ask me permission first you know
when I went to see Bill Burr did I
bother Bill Burr not at all
I'm friends with
did I bother Bill bear not at all
Dean called me and he goes hey I'm going
to be in Jersey with Bill Friday night
do you want to come to the show and I'm
like dog I'll come to the show let me
know I'll tell my wife to get tickets I
went for the tickets first
right he goes no no no I'll ask Bill
I'll get two tickets so he goes I don't
comp anybody anything Bill company I go
fine
I didn't when [__] he got to town
Friday he called he we were going to
hook up for like a early dinner
he didn't [__] he couldn't make it
next thing you know
I said I'll just meet you at the thing
next thing you know Bill reached out and
he goes do you want to park behind a
building I didn't ask him for nothing I
wasn't going to civilian I didn't give a
[__] next thing you know I go yeah I'll
strip behind the [__] I'll park
behind the building at bmac whatever the
[__] njpac whatever the [__] it is
and when I get there right before I'm
parking he's like hey hurry up I want
you to do a guest set guest set I think
company to do a guess that I can't wait
to see Bill my wife wanted to see Bill
so I just wanted to go with my wife and
maybe I'd laugh a little bit that's it
it's great to go to things as a [__]
spectator but I didn't go expecting to
do 30 minutes and watch this I'm going
to go up in front of no I just went to
watch and hang out he just asked me and
I was like pretty happy that he asked me
and again it's not what you say it's
highly the [__] you say it so if you
want somebody to give you a guess that
no go expectations don't tell him you
want to bring [__] 50 people to the
show they don't need to hear that [__]
just tell them the truth I'm an open
microman I've been banging it out for a
while it would be great to be a part of
a [__] show do you can I have five
minutes I mean don't hit me up for the
28th I already got guest sets man and I
got Dean coming and I got Lee coming I
got dyra coming and uh it's a theater so
it too many people if I do a club you
can always call me for guests people
always [__] do sometimes I'm in the
position of Doom and sometimes I'm not
sometimes I'm waiting to see how you ask
that's everything that's the most
important thing if you come up to me
cocky like you [__] you the world
owes you something I'ma tell you to go
[__] yourself you know what I'm saying
and that's it
that's the Monday morning [__]
podcast guys I come at you once a week
cause like I told Robert Keller last
week I ain't got much to [__] say you
know what I'm saying I got
I'm living my life it's simple
I'm not doing the things I was doing
anymore I mean I'm still doing my bong
hits
I'm having a good time raising my
daughter and uh this is the best I got
to offer guys
couple weeks we got a podcast scheduled
down and maybe start doing one on
Wednesday uh let's see what we're gonna
do
and we'll take it from that guys
but right now I'm not busting my hump I
just want to come on here and remind you
[__]
of your responsibilities is church
members and Joint members that we got a
sling dick
with three [__] hands every goddamn
day
we don't take [__] from nobody it's the
beginning of the [__] Year guys we
got the World by the balls this is not a
[__] race
this is a marathon and pick and choose
make great decisions and your 2023 will
be a lot better than 2022 will be where
are the [__] weeds I mean we're done
now it's balls the [__] out even my
[__] father-in-law who's Johnny
America
Johnny [__] America my father-in-law
I love him to death he got covered he
called me and my wife up and he's like
this is [__] [__] this man has
never cursed in front of me in 23 years
and he called covid [__]
this is [__] he never had covert
before he don't leave the house my
father-in-law he's sick my mother-in-law
does everything but my mother-in-law God
I gave it to my father-in-law and that's
exactly what he said he didn't say [__]
and I'm exaggerating now I'm
bullshitting you guys he said this is
[__] when I heard it my jaw [__]
dropped it's not that bad no no he was
like in shock that we've lost this much
[__] sleep
and this much time over this [__]
like he was [__] yelling and
screaming and this is what's happening
right now
that a lot of Americans that were
[__] Believers to the end they're
going what the [__]
because they're in Tennessee this is
Middle America where [__] counts
Shack
and when you turn on those [__]
people
you know New York L.A we're [__] a
bunch of saps you know you know I love
covid you know we don't [__] know
[__]
that's the real heart of America this
[__] was like this is [__]
this is what you shut the [__] world
down for [__] three years and scare
people and face masks and the whole
thing
you know it's it's done it's done
for when people like that start saying
this is [__] it's over knock it out
of your system the fear is over you're
not gonna [__] die
have you seen what they're coming out
with lately this [__] booster
now people are dying now people are
stroking out over 65 they're having
strokes and a dear dear friend of mine
told me that this [__] rooster wasn't
was tested like on three monkeys and one
and one cheetah or something I'm making
up stories here this is covered
misinformation when I'm talking about
the cheating [__] but that not to take
the booster because they didn't really
taste they tested like on three humans I
don't even know I don't even [__]
know but for my father-in-law to talk
like that you know it's over guys don't
believe the hype you got nothing
stopping you but yourself now it's
January 2023 that [__] story don't
let them scare you don't believe the
[__] hype and go for it I'm sick and
[__] tired
of people trying to hold us back not
even like you know it's not communism
it's not Cuba the person can hold you
back the most is you but for other
people to [__] tell you like oh this
that [__] these [__] guys go
for it it's over it's a [__] cold
nobody's gonna die from dick okay the
most dangerous party a day is when you
[__] drive somewhere for those that
don't know it I love you stay black hey
don't forget my little [__] buddy
Todd over there at uh
oh Stoner club with some tremendous bro
those Edibles he's got over there he's
got these 500 milligram bags like I
think they come in green apple a Grape
Ape I mean I like the little ones the 15
milligram ones and I like the chocolate
true those ones the true dose Edibles
are [__] stronger than [__] but he's
got these bags I think they come out to
500 milligrams for the whole bag the
grape ones dog this times I eat those
[__] and I don't know where I'm
at because you can't eat the same
Edibles every day you know what I'm
saying but don't forget get the stoner
Club
uh.com enter code Uncle Joey and get 10
off for Lifetime and then deliver right
to your [__] house guys they're not
[__] around it's like I said it's not
people who look like gang bangers coming
into your neighborhood they're pretty
decent people Dez and the other guy are
[__] great people but
that's it it's another [__] week for
you to be the best that you can be and
we'll be back next Monday
as good as we could be Tip Top Magoo I
love you [__] stay black have a
great week and now for a word from our
sponsors
all right that's it you bad
[__] thank you for supporting
and stopping by today this episode is
sponsored by better help when life gets
you feeling overwhelmed working with a
therapist makes you more prepared to
take on anything life grows at you
therapy is important it helped me and it
can help you better help is the therapy
option that is convenient flexible
affordable and entirely online fill out
a brief questionnaire get matched with a
licensed therapist and switch therapist
anytime for no additional charge if you
want to live more empowered life therapy
can get you there
visit betterhelp.com Diaz today to get
you 10 off your first month that's
betterhelp.com Diaz the joint is also
brought to you by rocket money how much
are you paying for your subscriptions
you don't even have a clue you're
probably wasting hundreds of dollars
each month on stuff that you forgot
about that's why I love rocket money
they're formerly known as true built
this app shows you all your
subscriptions in one place and cancels
whatever ones you don't want rocket
money can even find you ones you didn't
even know you were paying for you may
even find out you've been double charge
how's that for you so the cancel
subscription press cancel and Rocket
money takes care of the rest it's that
easy get rid of useless subscriptions of
Rocket money now go to rocketmoney.com
Joey again
that's rocketmoney.com Joey you could
save hundreds a year with
rocketmoney.com Joey
DraftKings is coming at you again this
week with UFC
283 Saturday night check out DraftKings
Sportsbook and official sports betting
part of the UFC witnessed the historic
match between figaretto against Moreno
for the fourth time that fight
unbelievable new customers can bet five
dollars and get 203 bets instantly
listen
I like this card a lot there's a couple
fights on here I like to talk about more
but it's Monday I gotta wait till Friday
for the weigh-in download the DraftKings
Sportsbook app today use promo code Joey
new customers can bet five dollars on
UFC 283 and get 200 and free bets
instantly that's code Joey only on
DraftKings Sportsbook the official
sports betting partner of the UFC
minimum age and eligibility restrictions
apply I want to thank DraftKings I want
to thank rocket money and I want to
thank
betterhelp.com I want to thank you guys
for having my back stay black I'll see
you guys next Monday tip top Magoo
[Music]
you know